Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody. We're down to just
the last two shows of the year, and in one sense,
the news has been kind of slow the last few days,
but in another sense we have entered what is maybe
the craziest time since the start of the
pandemic in terms of the coming together of
number one, extreme pandemic fatigue. Number
two, an outrageously contagious variant
with record number of cases which officially
are not even close to what the real number of
infections is. And we will talk to that, and it
is abundantly clear that the next, I would say
six to eight weeks are going to be extremely,
extremely unstable in terms of the range of the
sorts of reports that we're going to get. So I
mean, let's just go through it. As predicted,
the extremely contagious Micron variant is rip
roaring its way through the United States record
numbers of cases over the last couple of days
as the data from the holiday weekend has been
processed. We had on yesterday three hundred
and thirteen thousand cases officially reported.
Now it's a crucial detail to understand. This is
nowhere close to the real number. If you do an at
home test and they're positive and then you don't
go and get a PCR at some location that officially
reports these numbers, that positive home case
doesn't show up in these numbers. In addition,
because somewhere between 40 and 60
percent of our micron infections are
completely asymptomatic or almost completely
asymptomatic, you might have a slight headache,
little scratchy throat, not even something that
would say to you, I've got to go get tested. A
ton of people aren't even getting tested,
never mind only getting a home test. So,
you know, Dr. Fauci talked about we might see
a million cases a day in the United States.
We may be there already when you have three
hundred and 12000 officially reported cases.
You can conservatively assume that between
home positive tests and people who don't
even get tested, you've got at least two times
that number, which would put us at about 650,
maybe even three times that number. So these
are completely incredible numbers. Other signs
that this is absolutely everywhere include
positivity rates in some places, New York City
now has a positivity rate of almost 20 percent.
Meaning if you go and just look at the percentage
of tests that are coming back positive, it's about
one out of five. Almost one in five New Yorkers
who took COVID tests received positive
results in the latest batch of data.
The latest case count is a drop, but overall
testing surged ahead of the holidays, skewing the
figures. In England, there is a report that if you
have cold symptoms, right, if you look at the sub,
this is now not a subset of people getting tested.
This is the this is a subset of just people with
cold symptoms. Half of them are believed to
have COVID. The American variant, which is now
dominant in the U.K. now on that note, are Macron
being dominant? This is the next level of chaos.
If you've been following the question
what percentage of American cases
are Macron versus Delta? There was a report
from about, I want to say, 10 days ago,
which said something like 75 percent of U.S.
cases were then Macron, suggesting that by now,
it's got to be close to 100 percent. Not so fast.
That data was mistaken. There is now a new report
from the CDC, which cuts the estimate of the
prevalence of al-Muqrin in the United States.
Macron is growing dramatically in the U.S.,
but the numbers we got were wrong. The CDC
revised downward the estimate of the
percentage of COVID that is now Macron.
According to agency data, al-Muqrin accounted
for 59 percent of all infections as of December
25th. Now remember the week of the 18th, they
said Macron is already 73 percent. Turns out
that was only 22 percent and the number is now
59 percent. So is our Macron more contagious
than Delta? Yes. Is it increasingly a larger
share of all US cases? Yes. But the numbers were
wrong. The numbers that we originally got were
wrong and the new estimates as the hill rates
mean that while a majority of new infections are
from Akron, Delta has not been sidelined and is
still about 41 percent of infections. So that
is again another change, which is we thought
that by now it would be all AMOC run. It turns
out that it is not. As of a few days ago, it was
about 60 percent, meaning 40 percent of cases are
still Delta, Delta and al-Muqrin, presenting with
different severity, different symptoms, different
level of vaccine evasion. Another element of chaos
is the CDC deciding to change the quarantine and
the isolation guidelines, and what I initially
suspected was a change mostly motivated by
economics and finance and meaning we just industry
wants people working seems to be exactly that
and so much confusion over these new guidelines.
The CDC has shortened recommended isolation and
quarantine periods for the general population.
The CDC is sort of saying it's medically oriented,
although many doctors are saying it's not really
clear that there's a medical justification here.
There's a debate about that right now. The new
rules are. CDC is shortening the recommended time
for isolation from 10 days to five days if you
have COVID. If you were asymptomatic, followed
by five days of wearing a mask around others,
the change is motivated by science, demonstrating
that the majority of transmission is happening
early in the one to two to two days prior to
symptoms and two to three days after. Of course,
if you don't have symptoms, it's hard to say which
are the one to two days before and two to three
days after. So this is this is the confusion.
The guideline now is if you test positive,
isolate five days. If you're still asymptomatic,
leave isolation, keep masking for five days.
Additionally, the CDC has updated the quarantine
period for those exposed, not infected.
If you're unvaccinated or more than six months out
from your second dose and not boosted quarantine
five days and then wear a mask for five days
if it's not feasible to quarantine, wear a mask
for 10 days if you've had your booster. You don't
need to quarantine after the exposure, but still
wear a mask for 10 days and for all exposed. Get
a test at day five if symptoms start quarantine
immediately until you get a negative test or can
confirm that your symptoms are not due to COVID.
The immediate question is is this is this just a
business thing? And Dr. Rochelle Walensky appeared
yesterday on CNN. First of all, was asked,
Why are we not demanding a negative test?
Listen to what she had to say.
Speaker 2: The U.K. has also shortened
its period of isolation to seven days, but with a
negative test on day six and day seven a negative
rapid test. Why didn't the CDC recommend
taking a rapid test after those five days?
Yeah, really important question. So we do,
just to be clear, recommend having a rapid test
during your period of quarantine after you've
been exposed, but we opted not for isolation.
That rapid test for isolation exactly. We
opted not to have the rapid test for isolation
because we actually don't know how our rapid
tests perform and how well they predict.
Whether you're transmissible during the end
of disease, the FDA has not authorized them
for that use. We don't know how they perform.
Speaker 1: So this is a really important point.
These rapid tests that many of us have have
relied on, they really are more accurate when
one is symptomatic and I'm going to talk today
about my my I faced off against Macron and I'm
going to tell you about it in rapid tests are
a big part of what I'm going to talk about. So
Dr. Rochelle Walensky saying, you know,
if you're asymptomatic and these cases,
it's not really clear how much
the rapid tests actually tell us.
And then the question comes about,
are these new recommendations
medically oriented or business oriented?
Speaker 2: So from what you're saying,
it sounds like this decision had just as much
to do with business as it did with the science.
Well, so it really had a lot to do with what we
thought people would be able to tolerate. We have
seen relatively low rates of isolation for all
of this pandemic. Some science has demonstrated
less than a third of people are isolating
when they need to. And so we really want to
make sure that we had guidance in this moment
where we were going to have a lot of disease
that could be adhered to that people were willing
to adhere to and that spoke specifically to when
people were maximally infectious. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So there is no doubt that a big
piece of this is just what are people willing
to tolerate, quite frankly. And so I am not
blaming anyone for any particular
wrongdoing. I'm pointing out that
the case numbers are so out of control. It
is not clear we can vaccinate our way out of
infection. We can hopefully vaccinate
our way out of serious illness and death.
Although although when I tell you my story
later, you might change your mind about that
as well. We'll get to that. Let's next talk
about the domestic travel vaccine requirement.